I have a unique theory about where this
all fits into the insidious timeline
stick around to the end of this video
where I'll discuss that in this first
shot there's a woman standing out in the
woods but upon closer inspection it may
not actually be a woman but maybe an owl
or something it looks like there could
also be someone looking at the window
there have been a lot of presences that
have made themselves known by appearing
in the window in the first three films
so my guess is we'll see that come back
in fact it's like 99% confirmed later in
the trailer I personally hope that we
get to see this guy again at some point
because he was one of my favorite spooks
from the original this is an RV kids a
set of lights that we use in the film
industry which come in an easily
transported container like this I'm not
saying that this character is gonna be a
filmmaker or anything sometimes we just
use equipment as props and set
decoration there are a lot of literal
keys in this trailer one of the big
questions is gonna be what does it all
mean the creature seems to put this key
into the girls vocal cords it cuts the
most mature way you can describe that
and looks to turn the key and lock away
her voice let's watch the clip again
[Applause]
[Music]
it's also more or less confirmed in the
international trailer where she goes
silent and the creature does this I'll
come back to the significance of that in
a moment
but another thing I noticed is that this
creature seems to be in our world
because while the lighting is a little
bit reminiscent of the further that
realm always has this low-lying ground
fog this scene does not the setting of
this film looks like the southwest USA
and in the international trailer it's
mentioned that the film takes place in
five keys New Mexico this is not a real
town so anything I deduct about the
setting in this video is intentionally
done that way by the filmmakers for
example the director chose to make this
welcome sign that looked like a
tombstone he also chose to make the
town's tagline will unlock your heart if
this creature can lock people's vocal
cords it stands to reason that he can
also lock away other parts of the body
as well in a metaphorical sense there
may be four things that make up who a
person really is we've seen each one
manifested by characters in The Wizard
of Oz for example you have their heart
which represents their desires their
voice which represents essentially
communication and friendship their mind
which obviously represents their
thoughts and how do I put this without
getting demonetised Kahuna's which
indicate courage there are other ways
you can break these basic human traits
down but you get the idea
now in the insidious movies in the
further we tend to see a bunch of human
spirits and this one demon who looks
like Darth Maul from what I can gather
this keymaster creature is another demon
from that world while Darth Maul's main
objective was to take over a human
vessel I think this new creature
operates a bit differently when a
character astral projects they're
putting themselves out there outside of
their human body and what they are
projecting is more or less the essence
of who they are their mind their heart
their voice or otherwise I think this
creature preys on people by either
locking specific traits outside of their
body or possibly locking them in and
effectively limiting their astral
abilities as you can imagine either of
these could be used to terrify someone
especially if you have to confront or
defeat this keymaster creature in order
to unlock yourself there's even more
importance to the keys than that though
in insidious the red faced demon has his
own domain in
further with the shackles the record
player and this claw sharpening device I
think this new demon's domain is going
to be this prison
which would make sense for him since
prisons are filled with locks and he's
literally made of keys speaking of the
layers of these demons I think they may
be the only clue to figuring out why
this clown thing is in the trailer this
is admittedly pretty weak but the only
connection I can make is to the clown
dolls we see in the red face demon's
lair in the International trailer we get
a peek at this girl's sketches and
they're very similar to the drawings
done by Dalton in insidious you'll also
notice that her mouth is stitched shut
which adds support to my idea of her
voice being locked by that creature now
I'm gonna get into the timeline stuff so
buckle in because it gets a bit
confusing
let me first review the timeline of
events so far so we're all in the same
page the earliest point we've seen so
far is Elise as a younger adult in
chapter 2 when she helps Josh Lambert
forget about his astral abilities as a
child this is also the period to which
the adult versions of these characters
travel back to see the origins of the
black bride as he's abused by his mother
the woman in white chronologically the
next time we see Elise is after her
retirement in Chapter three she comes
out of retirement to help Quinn Brenner
eradicate the man who can't breathe and
reconnect with her late mother by that
time the black bride is grown up and the
lease has to fight it off this is also
where she meets specs and tugger a few
years later the events of the original
movie unfold at least helps the lab
retractor son Dalton from the further
and Josh Lambert has to relearn how to
astral projects in order to do so at the
end that black bride possesses Josh's
body and kills Elise that leads us to
the present portion of chapter 2 where
Elise's spirit in the further drives out
the black bride from Josh's body just
before he kills his family so where does
this 4th installment take place let's
look at the trailer again Elise seems to
be telling the story as a flashback
these hauntings
can be terrifying things I should know
I've faced many evils in my life
we're then shown clips from each of the
three insidious movies
she also says this was different though
keyword was so we know she's telling a
story from the past and the story is
being told from sometime after the scene
in Chapter two the story she's telling
takes place after Chapter three we know
that because she's already working with
specks and Tucker
but before insidious because she's not
dead in this story we hear her say in
the following the haunted house it's my
family's house I think we're actually
gonna see flashbacks within the
flashback that frames the movie and get
a look in on Elise's childhood and the
young adult years as a result
notice how this girl and Elise are never
in the same shot maybe it's because
they're the same person
it makes sense because they both astral
projects I can see thanks to here's the
best piece of evidence though the girl
examines this jacket in the house if you
pause at just the right moment the
nametag shows a first name ending in a
last name
Rainier which is also Elise's last name
her husband is mentioned in Chapter
three and his name is Jack which if you
aren't aware does not end in the letter
O my theory is that the jacket belongs
to Elise's father who also seems to be
assistant warden at the prison the
lurking place of the keymaster creature
may be the keymaster is connected
somehow to Elise's relationship with her
father maybe they're even the same
person I think the way the International
trailer is edited also suggests that the
girl in the lease are one in the same
older releases attacked and younger
Elise goes flying it's treated as one
sequence she also looks similar enough
to the younger version of Elise from
Chapter two in addition to Elise as a
young adult we'll also see her as a
child take a closer look at how this
little girl responds to the name Elise
nice so if everything I predicted is
true then maybe this character right
here is a younger version of the bride
in black we see him as a child in
Chapter two being scolded for using a
male named Parker and we know he has the
elder female alter ego who killed 15
people we also know that he's followed
her for a very long time the wallpaper
in this trailer for the new movie
matches the wallpaper in Parker's room
and there may or may not be a connection
between the butterflies and Elise's
shirt and those on the wall in Parkers
room there may be other references as
well so let me know what you saw in the
comments if you're excited for this
movie let me know by leaving this video
a like and if you're a fan of horror
which I'm assuming you are if you're
here at this point you're gonna want to
subscribe to this channel see Z's world
for new Horrors every week later today
I'll be on the air with Lady White
Rabbit and mortis media for a new
episode of our live show the dead stream
so join us for that at 2 p.m. Pacific 5
p.m. Eastern that's 10 p.m. GMT all you
have to do is ring the death Bell for
notifications and I'll see you this
afternoon
assuming we both survive